Speaker 1: This is absolutely bizarre for
a number of reasons.
Donald Trump's indicted former national security
adviser, Michael Flynn, who has since been
pardoned and is a total outand out conspiracy
theorist, appeared on some right wing show
a few days ago and claimed that, yes, the
election was stolen and yes, covid was a conspiracy
and all of this stuff.
But as crazy as all of that is, he drops in.
He's not worried because he's been on hydroxy
chloroquine for 30 years.
What why has he been on hydroxy chloroquine
for 30 years?
And why would you need to be on hydroxy chloroquine
if covid is a hoax anyway?
None of it's none of it makes sense.
Why has he been taking the virus?
Why why has he been taking the medication?
What did he know in nineteen ninety one at
age thirty two, that would start him on a
30 year course of hydroxy chloroquine.
Just some of the questions that come up.
Let's take a listen to Michael Flynn,
Speaker 4: because when you look around the
world and you go all these other places, why
are all these other places having the kinds
of problems that we keep getting beat over
the head and shoulders on in this country
about when it comes to COGAT?
Why?
Because everything.
Everything and this is this is my my truth.
But what I believe everything is a distraction
to what happened on the 3rd of November.
So everything that we hear about covid and
that Kabbage started before the third in November,
but it was all meant to control.
It's all meant to gain control of a society,
to be able to to force decisions on the society
instead of actually allowing the people
Speaker 1: to make decisions.
Imagine for a moment, and this is this is
the tragedy.
That guy was the national security adviser
of the United States for a period of time.
OK, I've heard from other people the idea
covid was created and released to make Trump
lose the election.
This is one of the conspiracies that doesn't
even make sense in terms of the motive.
Sometimes you have a bad conspiracy theory
and all they have is motive.
They have no facts, but at least the motive
sort of might work to convince you that it's
a possible conspiracy.
Covid was created to make Trump lose.
The American election doesn't even pass the
sniff test because there's no guarantee that
covid would make a world leader up for reelection
lose if they handled the virus correctly.
Never mind that we've had six hundred thousand
official deaths.
The world has had three and a half million
Most of the deaths are not in the US.
So Flynn is wrong that we are mostly affected
and everybody else is fine.
Most of the deaths have been in other countries.
Second, if you handle covid well, you get
yourself reelected.
Look at New Zealand, where Jacinda Ardern
handled the virus beautifully, easily, got
reelected and New Zealand was able to reopen
much earlier than the United States.
So to assume Trump loses because of covid
is sort of silly.
Unless you assume Trump would mishandle it,
which isn't as crazy, but it still goes against
the idea of what Michael Flynn is saying.
But then he casually mentions, I've been on
hydroxy chloroquine for 30 years
Speaker 4: and now with the with the vaccine
as an example.
Right.
Whatever happened to the woman's movement
out there for the my body, my choice.
But yet they want to stick a needle in my
arm to tell me that if you don't have that
needle, you can't get an ID card.
You can't get you can't travel.
Wait a second.
I'm as healthy as the next.
Robin, I've been taking hydrochloric acid
for 30 years.
Speaker 1: OK, so by by the way, more lies
there.
No one has said you can't get a state ID if
you don't get a vaccine.
And in terms of travel, there are countries
that are putting in place a vaccine requirement
for covid vaccine.
For decades and decades, different countries
have had different vaccine requirements.
That's nothing new.
OK, but hydroxy chloroquine for 30 years.
Michael Flynn is 62 years old right now, meaning
30 years ago he would have been thirty two
and it would have been nineteen ninety one.
Why did he start taking hydroxy chloroquine
in nineteen ninety one at thirty two years
of age?
Has he had arthritis since age 30 to one of
the reasons sometimes people take hydroxy
chloroquine.
Has he been persistently exposed to malaria
for the last thirty years where he needs to
constantly be on hydroxyl chloroquine?
Has he had lupus since age thirty to another
reason why sometimes you would take hydroxy
chloroquine if you take it for just five years,
you need to get regular eye exams because
it can cause retinopathy.
And Michael Flynn claims that he's been on
hydroxy chloroquine for thirty years.
Or is Michael Flynn implying that as a prophylactic
of some kind, he's been taking hydroxy chloroquine
for thirty years, which just makes no sense
whatsoever?
And I got one funny email, which was, you
know, maybe thirty years of hydroxy chloroquine
have caused some kind of toxicity.
And that explains all of Michael Flynn's bizarre
behavior, the paranoid delusions, the conspiracy
theories, all of it, I don't know.
And to come back again to the entire covid
hoax thing, if it's a hoax, why do you need
to take anything?
Why take hydroxy chloroquine for something
that's not real, if that's indeed what you
believe?
And of course, by hoax, they always mean different
things.
Sometimes by hoax, they mean it's not really
a virus and nobody's dying from it.
By hoax, sometimes they mean no, it's a real
virus and people are dying.
But it was deliberately released to have a
political impact either on the United States
or the world or whatever the case may be.
It's never clear they're conspiracy theories,
conflict.
But what is abundantly clear here is that
Michael Flynn is completely off the rails.
And it is terrifying, terrifying that that
guy at one point was the primary and most
important adviser on the topic of national
security to the president of the United States.